coming from like a small town in
Cleveland like it took a lot of getting
used to
Jake Paul has gone from vine star to
Disney star and now at just 19 he's
published a memoir and is even living
with his group of collaborators known as
team 10 were really really good friends
we're also each other's like number one
supporters we're all working together to
like take over Hollywood
Paul has more than 5 million followers
on vine alone so et had to ask does this
social media superstar keep anything
under wraps there's so much that you
share online through various platforms
is there anything that you feel like you
ever won't share I think I show about
80% which is a lot especially now that
yeah I'm vlogging every single day every
day posting it online so but what's in
that 20% you know I think things like
relationships drama like the boring
stuff like that's not the four taxis
well that's true that's true that's true
are you gonna share that at all with
people I don't know I mean I think maybe
eventually you just have to keep some
sort of privacy just so that like you
can disconnect from the world if you
need to
Paul says his memoir does show some of
that more private side this is kind of
more about those like 20% things or
before I got big on social media there
was 16 years when like I had 10
followers so it was about like those
experiences that I went through in those
like 16 years I made a lot of mistakes
along the way I kind of shaped Who I am
today and so I felt like I could relate
to kids or or maybe kids who feel like
they're making a lot of mistakes and
there's no hope for them that they could
read this and go hey you know Jake made
this really big mistake when he was you
know 14 and then now look where he is so
like either still hope for me and I can
accomplish big things
you